hello everyone Bandit here and it's
Christmas because we have a brand new
and final trailer for tears of the
Kingdom 2 analyze so let's get right
into it our opening shot is of the
clouds far above Hyrule showcasing a
sunrise over the sky islands or Sky rule
as I like to call them from the other
angles we can even see more cube-like
Zone eye structures that might just be
platforms but also might have more
secrets than initially meets the eye the
next shot again showcases Sky rule this
time with a choo-choo fighting off
against one of the constructs this is
interesting because choo choos originate
from down in Hyrule or so one would
think if they're present up in Sky rule
perhaps this is the final proof that
many of these sky islands have indeed
risen from the ground below the next
shot is a closer one of one of the
constructs apparently cutting down a
tree as we saw in the gameplay reveal
some of the constructs are not initially
hostile towards link perhaps they're
building shelters for themselves or are
trying to achieve some sort of common
goal that we have yet to uncover the
next shot is of Link heroically diving
towards the surface we can once again
see many sky islands in the background
including the large v-shaped building
which we can now see close up it appears
to be a massive multi-layered structure
that just screams dungeon to me as link
Falls we see Hyrule and the logo of the
game appear in front of us while the
music takes a classic spin the next shot
kicks off a series of shots that all
serve to Showcase hyrule's many changes
most of which are due to fall and debris
from the world above as we can see in
this shot we also have a better View at
this new not chica Tower structure thing
that apparently is located right beside
kakarika Village according to this giant
zonai ruin that has a hole in it that we
see later on the next shot showcases
hateno Village but for some reason
everyone is really into mushrooms the
fashion shop has a mushroom dress
there's a mushroom Tower mushroom tree
looking things and even mushroom hats
being worn by the various citizens
intriguing to say the least but not
anything that I can speak to right now
next we have a shot of tents going up in
Hyrule Castle town which does not appear
to have been repaired very much at all
following its initial destruction 100
years prior to the events of breath of
the wild however it's possible that
these tents are here because of the
efforts to repair the castle town and
due to things we can see in previous
trailers and this one I believe will be
able to assist with the repairs all
throughout Hyrule next we have a shot of
Link climbing above kakarika Village
along with the opposite closer angle to
the zonai donut or zonut structure
resting on top of some hills there is a
zonai shrine located below as well there
are scaffoldings spread out through the
hills surrounding the village but it's
unclear as to what their purpose is I
could only assume the shika are
attempting to research the Fallen ruins
next we have a swooping shot of Link
running through some zonai ruins towards
a great tornado in the sky this tornado
appears to be the same one showcased in
the game's art which may be located
above the Hebrew mountains if this is
the area that link is exploring with the
Rito individual later on that would make
sense next we have a shot of the Gerudo
desert with something rumbling
underneath the ground an overhead shot
reveals new zonai structures present in
the desert and the following shot
reveals a giant previously unseen zonai
structure actually rising from the
ground now a structure rising from
underneath the Gerudo desert would imply
to many fans of the series a return to
the arbiter's grounds or perhaps the
spirit temple from Ocarina of Time but
but the fact that it is clearly a Zone
ice structure and not a Gerudo structure
does hurt this concept although at this
point anything is possible either way it
will most likely serve to be another
dungeon though in the next shot we see
many falling pieces of Sky rule most of
which appear to Glow with the zonai
magic that link should be able to use
his recall ability on ganondorf's theme
plays on the piano in the background as
we look at the Risen castle and we see
chica individuals looking at the falling
structures with much concern to the left
we can see what appears to be a house or
a building that's in the process of
being built again something I believe
link will be able to help with in the
game and also a reason to see bols in
construction I hope the next shot is one
of my favorite because clearly it's a
shot of Ganondorf whose hair is now red
and glowing with malice this is
obviously after the events happen within
the castle as proven by Ganondorf
standing outside somewhere looking at
the giant blood moon we can see flowers
around where he's standing which could
be a balcony of Hyrule Castle or perhaps
somewhere on the ground immediately
outside Ganondorf basks in the glow of
the blood moon and just as he turns
around we cut to Black and moments later
we see the familiar shot of Link
desperately trying to save Zelda from
falling which he actually fails at
however as Zelda Falls we see a glow
begin to happen around her body this is
the exact same kind of glow that happens
to link whenever he's being warped by
Zelda in breath of the wild which to me
means that Zelda is being warped here
but the questions are by who and to
where allegedly her powers are gone at
this point could this be the work of
someone else who also has the light
powers of hylia and who is calling Zelda
to their side the next shot shows link
traversing Gerudo desert which looks
quite a bit different now on account of
all the sinkholes present we can't see
down into any of these sinkholes from
this angle but these could hide enemies
inside them or perhaps they are holes
that link can fall through to enter the
underground structures that we see in
the previous trailer with all the ruined
pillars sticking out around the ground
immediately surrounding the sinkholes
though one might be able to conclude
that the sinkholes lead into whatever
structure used to be here and since
these pillars are clearly not zonai per
perhaps this is the arbiter's grounds in
the background we can see a familiar
dust storm in Gerudo desert as well as
new zonai structures and one of the
ground tattoos sprawled out along the
side of the gruda Highlands in the next
shot we see a link running in familiar
armor which proves that at least some
armor sets are making a reappearance as
well as the Liz all Shield link is
running towards a huge underground
structure with lava falling on either
side and probably flowing underneath his
feet as well from what we know in breath
of the wild this has to be the interior
of Death Mountain however it's also
possible that it is just underneath
Death Mountain or is a new underground
area entirely since we've been showcased
that in previous trailers I would assume
this structure is either a city for link
to explore or a dungeon the next shot
showcases multiple flying Zone eye ships
that look like warships because of this
and a few other things in the trailer I
believe the zonai are forming an army to
battle against the forces of Ganondorf
which link will join perhaps even
explaining his change in attire we also
see the storming tornado in the
background perhaps link will need the
assistance of these warships in order to
enter the tornado next we see link do
some sort of low gravity jump into a
floating water bubble which he get this
can swim inside of without surfacing
clearly link will be able to swim in
water in this game at least that's what
this means to me the water bubbles also
contain Zodi construction pieces and
assumedly are how link will Traverse to
the other side of this zonai structure
next we have a very fast shot of Link
descending quickly dodging Zone eye
lasers on the way down it is entirely
unclear what he is descending into but
we can probably assume it is the
underground he pops open a new wingsuit
which appears to be Rito in origin this
probably helps with assisting Link in
slow falling and having greater Glide
Maneuvers then we see link inside a
dome-like flying Island potentially one
we see later in the trailer pushing a
giant lever facing a giant bubble gum
dispenser that dispenses giant orbs
which resembled the sheikah orbs that
link needed to solve many puzzles in the
first game perhaps these will be useful
in solving this giant structure next we
see link gliding through a zonai
structure that very heavily humbles the
Labyrinth from breath of the wild
there's not much to go off of here
though so moving on next we see link
twirling a new spear going into battle
on Horseback against some moblins and
mcgoblins but what's even more is that
we see hylians fighting alongside him
perhaps link can recruit people for his
own Army and tears of the Kingdom which
we'll get to later next we see link
ascending on a familiar looking chica
elevator which is actually kind of
refreshing to see at this point however
the biggest giveaway is the fact that he
is holding the Nintendo switch I mean
the Chica slate-like device in his hand
the official art of Zelda shows her
holding it so this is a bit
contradictory although it can be assumed
that link picks it up after she
disappears after falling link also
appears to have some sort of cable
spooled on his chest that is connected
to the Chica switch supposedly powering
it on the Chica text behind League reads
transport the next shot is an incredible
facial reveal of either a zonai or the
zonai that we've been seeing on the
murals a couple trailers ago for those
of you who have seen the leaked art book
you know what this individual's name is
but I will not say it here for those who
have not either way though this person
is a very very big deal and I think the
one leading the zonai armies against
Ganondorf we can see individuals
standing behind him which may be other
members of the zonai army link turns
around on Horseback in the next shot but
nothing more in the next shot a giant
Zone eye construct awakens from the wall
in a black Sky environment which may be
underground and something tells me this
isn't going to be a very friendly
meeting for link next we have a very
peculiar shot of Link in the throne room
with its sparkling see this is either a
flashback which isn't very likely or
it's time travel because if you'll
recall the throne room is kind of
occupied at the moment and not to
mention destroyed due to the events at
the end of breath of the wild but if
link is shown already having his new
zonai Shield then how is he here seeing
the throne room like this maybe all the
Sparkles everywhere are implying
something magical going on like I said
either a flashback or time travel after
the brief cut to Black we are finally
shown Zelda after her rapid descent
she's standing in new zonai attire in
front of a Zone I shrine line of sorts a
voice begins speaking to her saying
Zelda we rely on your night and that
legendary sword he carries as it shows
Link's normal hand not Zone I hand
grasping the master sword The Voice
continues saying our last line of
defense will be link which again proves
to me that link is indeed joining the
forces of the zonai against Ganondorf
next we are shown Zelda facing the zonai
figure we saw before whose name I still
can't say let's just call him Richard we
see Richard's clothing which has
familiar zonai shapes and ornaments as
he places his hand on Zelda's shoulder a
close-up of Zelda's face reveals more of
her new attire and her lack of memory of
Link at least at first since it takes
her a hot second to remember him which
implies so many things time travel a new
body Resurrection you name it but
something happened to make her forget
she's wearing a magatama as a necklace
which will be important for a visual
later on next we see link looking cool
as hell flying on a new zonai glider
across the sky islands with Manny being
visible in the background Hyrule below
also showcases new malice-filled areas
which seem to contrast rest of the zonai
swirl structures next up we see link
fighting some constructs with a shield
sword which is probably the coolest
thing I've ever seen which he no doubt
created out of the use of his fuse
ability next we see link flying above
Eastern Hyrule towards a giant spinning
sphere Island which I think could be the
structure he's shown inside of earlier
in the trailer perhaps it's like a giant
Divine Beast or dungeon of sorts that he
has to solve in order to find another
megatama perhaps next we see link facing
off against some kind of flaming ball
monster thing that shoots out at him as
what appears to be two Goron children
watch perhaps this is some sort of trial
that the gorons have come up with or
perhaps it's just for sport Link's armor
and the Goron lanterns implies that this
area is in fact Death Mountain then we
see link and who appears to be Tulin
tiba's son flying upwards In The Sky
Islands they bounce off of a giant
trampoline that if I didn't know any
better feels pretty Rito in origin this
along with some other reveals later on
implies that link will be able to take
companions along with him in his
journeys some of which I our champion
descendants as link flies upward we can
also see the zonai warships in the
background meaning these things are
moving around in real time next we see
what I believe to be one of many side
quests in the rebuilding of Hyrule the
assistance of moving a family whose
wagon had been broken link can repair
all sorts of things with the ultra hand
so why not use it to assist those in
need next we'll see link utilize recall
in combat against an octrock which is
finally going to be an easy way to get
rid of those pesky enemies also if
you'll notice when link activates recall
time freezes while he's making his
choice now whether or not this is an
upgrade to recall it is no doubt going
to be very helpful in combat next we see
link attach his arm to a rocket a zonai
rocket actually in order to explore
space the final frontier or okay maybe
just Sky rule interestingly enough it's
possible that link is on even tight
Island here although I'm not entirely
sure about that it does appear to be
some sort of island off of the east
coast of Hyrule though which is very
interesting the cabins can be seen
building structures and being upset like
they do then we see link doing the low
gravity jumps once again across floating
zonai platforms this is very interesting
either gravity gets lighter the higher
he goes or it's lessened on some of the
sky islands or there's an updraft or
this is one of Link's new abilities we
haven't fully seen yet in the background
we see orbs of something approaching one
of the islands it is entirely unclear
what these are but they have little
green orbs inside them so that's cool
then we see Link in an intense looking
conflict with a construct riding
alongside him in a minecart above lava
link is able to defeat it and in the
background we can see what looks like
the underground area from the previous
trailer meaning this lava area must be
underground again perhaps underneath
Death Mountain next is one of my
favorite shots of any trailer ever and
it is neon Zelda Evangelion essentially
because just as the bakobans are riding
atop a stone Palace link has literally
constructed a giant block fighting
machine Mecha anime thing with a little
arm with which to mess up his enemies
this just makes me so happy and I could
rattle on but we're just gonna move on
next next we see link riding horseback
firing an arrow which has a ruby
attached to it giving it explosive
Firepower I hope it's a very powerful
era because that's an expensive
attachment and as the camera pans over
to Link's face we can see horns atop his
head now I'm assuming these aren't
growths but are rather a new headpiece
that we can collect in the game and who
knows what effects it will grant link
next we see a familiar bacoblin camp
with a zonai structure that link
activates the structure which appears to
be a simple zonai wheel with lasers
attached activates and begins firing
lasers in all directions eliminating
everything around it and imagine putting
one of these on a giant construct
machine and and just all the
possibilities Game of the Year People
Game of the Year anyway next up we see
Link in the Rito allegedly Inside the
Tornado while an absolutely
bone-chillingly terrifying giant monster
lunges for them from beneath and this
giant monster may actually be what was
responsible for the large tornado and I
cannot wait to face it in combat and
kill it Link's own eye armor is also
glowing as well as the Rito's gear which
could be due to the approxima committee
to the monster perhaps next we see the
familiar malice explosion from Ganondorf
and then an immediate cut to Zelda
standing outside in skyrimal holding the
magatama that she was previously wearing
as a necklace she says I know why I am
here it's something only I can do which
implies a connection to hylia as that is
pretty much Zelda's entire impact on the
franchise as a whole the magatama she
holds has the same symbol AS Link's
recall as well as the same glowing color
to me this means that either Zelda is
leaving these magatamas around for link
to find or she also has the power of
recall in this Relic next we see
Ganondorf exploding the mouse out of his
chest and said malice traveling Skyward
opening a portal that looks similar to
the portals the dragons would travel
into in breath of the wild I have no
doubt that this portal is what breaks
the separation between skyrill and
Hyrule and is the Catalyst for
everything with NC ganondorf's monsters
becoming super powered by the super
malice flying throughout Hyrule
including our first look at the new
lionels with their new even more
intimidating horns ganondorf's voice can
again be heard saying do not look way
you witness a king's Revival and the
birth of his new world as it shows the
malice somehow tainting the otherwise
all-powerful master sword and spreading
the Link's arm then we get to see the
best shot of the entire trailer and that
is ladies and gents rehydrated Ganondorf
looking absolutely amazing if I might
add with a nose as mighty as ever he
stares directly into the camera as he
lets loose a mighty yell with the gem on
his forehead glowing as his power surges
from the light of the blood moon and let
me just take one more moment to comment
on how amazing this moment feels for
Zelda fans from all generations to
finally see Ganondorf again for the
first time since Twilight Princess which
was nearly 20 years ago let that sink in
link runs from a new underground monster
that looks quite terrifying and lives in
skyrule then flies downward with the
Rito child who tells him okay let's go
then we see who looks to be Zelda but
going through some kind of
transformation into a zonai with her
skin darkening in her ears expanding but
still retaining her family your soft
eyes and her magatama necklace which is
now glowing as she appears to charge up
a power in her hand it's unclear if this
power that she was charging up is this
huge bolt of light energy that shoots
out across these moldugas but it
definitely seems like it also the
molduga is getting shot back in the air
is actually really funny then we see
riju grown since we last saw her
performing a sword dance and summoning
lightning just like her ancestor or Bosa
before her and just looking amazing and
intimidating in general then we see link
standing with all sorts of people
donning all sorts of gear even a bucket
could this be some sort of ragtag army
that link can form and even gear up an
unfamiliar voice says but you are not
alone while link fights alongside sidon
against a fancy looking construct which
implies that link will be able to take
Champions alongside him and perhaps even
form his own armies which opens up so
many possibilities then we see link
looking at something unknown and a
close-up of riju inside and antiba
charging against an enemy and I'd like
to point out that sidon appears to have
a magatama on his hand which which I
don't think he had previously which
could imply new powers for him perhaps
link is then shown running towards a
terrifying glioc with eyes made of
malice and fire on top of all its Heads
This is one fight I cannot wait to
experience Zelda's voice can be heard
saying link you are our final hope as
she grasps the master sword which goes
against the whole time travel
speculation because there's no reason
she would hold the master sword unless
it was because it's damaged now if you
watched my previous video you'll know
that I believe recall is perhaps one of
the biggest new abilities in the game
because it's what link is using when
repairing the master sword and also
apparently what Zelda can use as well so
perhaps Zelda assists with link
recalling the blade after the logo plays
we have one final shot of Zelda sitting
alone atop an unknown area in Sky roll
saying link you must find me and the
last thing we hear is Zelda's Lullaby
theories upon theories must be made but
for now that is the end of my analysis
if you enjoyed it please leave a like on
the video as that greatly helps get the
video spread out online and the past few
trailer analyzes I've uploaded have all
hit the trending page so let's see if we
can do it again and if you're excited
for the game subscribe if you haven't
already because all I can say is here we
go I look forward to seeing you in the
next one and thank you so very much for
watching if I missed anything please let
me know what you found in the comments
below that's all I've got for this one
so this is Bandit signing out
[Music]
thank you